and for me I'm just such a rabbit
attention [__] I've got to be the
center of attention like I've just got
to and like it's just so built into me
that I've got to be up there doing it
well I know your name's on the on your
bus in front with his face his face
yeah I mean you must have [__] people
you know because these you guys were in
a bus and and everything is Stevo so
when you're driving down the street
right people have [__] street right I
think that's crazy how does that work
with your relationship you're married or
I'm engaged you're gonna wear a ring out
of respect for for my fiance cool and
then how does it work work with because
I I've had a very difficult time and
that kind of uh um uh romantic yeah that
thing because you know I was talking to
Wolf as well is like he's got his wife
because all of us are very similar I
don't want to use the word narcissistic
because that's not a right word but
we're like you know all about everyone
in the business we're in the business of
us correct so so how does that work with
your girl going dude enough for your
[__] Stevo [__] right like yo
babe we gotta we gotta go have some
sushi let's just go chill and you're
like but because uh because we're
looking at our lives like yo [__] we
only got so much time to live and we
only have so much time to [__] create
[__] right and every time I present with
you that I'm taking out time because uh
the biggest currency in life is time
sure that's it you know what I mean the
money and this is that because we're all
going under the dirt anyways at some
point right so she takes you away
because that's part of the reason why
it's really hard for me to be with one
you know because they want to be with
you like so what do you do she my girl
um works in the entertainment industry
as a set designer a stylist you know uh
like wardrobe Specialists and she's kind
of been in the mix she like she's very
candid about uh you know it's it's it's
kind of tough like I've always you know
like I'm a hot chick you know like she
said she had a really tasteful and and
uh you know appropriate way to say that
she's been used to getting attention all
of her life and that it's very jarring
it's now being in in a relationship
where all the attention comes to me and
uh welcome to being a dude she had a
really
um she had a really uh healthy and
appropriate way of expressing that and
she she's very good at kind of just like
uh okay you know she humors me a lot she
puts up with me a lot and um she helps
me accomplish a lot so so when you're
saying that the relationships have
distracted you from from what you want
to accomplish I've actually got a
partner who's contributing to to my uh
my goals being achieved so do you do you
when you're about to do bits you know
the thing on the Tesla or this so you
run it by her or yeah she didn't love
the Tesla thing yeah she didn't love the
Tesla thing because she knew that in a
matter of 24 hours that I was going to
be assembling a frame to hold a car and
she's like no like yeah but that's
you're Stevo I mean what is she what is
she what did she sign up for did she not
see all the other [__] it's like you're
gonna stop she she just doesn't want me
dead she doesn't want me to die yeah
well I mean [__] I mean you're in the
business of you could right that's
that's true you know what I mean she got
through it she got through it yeah you
would never see a Jewish stunt man like
him that Juju something like I'm scared
just to walk on this bus you know what I
mean yeah it seems like he's like in
less than 24 hours I'm gonna you mean
less in less than six hours you know we
pulled that together pretty [__]
quick well yeah what like the welding
began like on the day you know well at
three o'clock in the afternoon we get
the text from Steve saying can you reach
out to construction companies to get to
get a crane built and we're like
they all close at five and then there's
like the red tape with insurance and so
it was like no let's get a crane so we
can do it ourselves and then all of a
sudden Steve was at a Tesla Place found
the guy to do it and that like by three
hours later they were all everybody's on
their way down to Sandy uh to Vegas and
everybody's building that so it's like
yeah it's really pretty cool man that uh
like the more crazy stuff I do the more
crazy stuff I'm able to do it's called
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on Amazon and type in Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're at
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude